the city is under some kind of terrorist
threat
he said something big was gonna happen
somebody has to punish the corrupt
I respected conviction
things he can make a difference
you believe in the devil you're fighting
a war this is just the beginning
you can't give in to the fear what are
you gonna do never takes the lone man
thinks he can make a difference
get out of my city
you
hey youtubers is Charlie so huge news
daredevil season 2 just cast the
Punisher it's actually Joe Bernthal from
The Walking Dead Shane is the Punisher
my initial reaction is of course Shane
is The Punisher that's what he was on
The Walking Dead that's totally his
character a lot of you guys asked me
earlier this year whenever they were
getting ready to premiere daredevil if
Punisher would ever enter the universe
because Marvel got the rights back to
him pretty recently
Netflix feels like the perfect place for
the character very low pressure you know
the problem with putting him in a movie
is is if it fails then they have to wait
like four or five years before they try
again just because it's such a bomb this
way he has Charlie Cox and the rest of
the supporting cast developing him
through 13 hours of television in an
ensemble just gives them much more time
to flesh out the character in a two-hour
movie Everwood plus it doesn't hurt that
they're on Netflix and they can be as
violent as they want you guys can let me
know whether you agree you know do you
feel like Netflix is the perfect place
for the Punisher character everyone
wants to see him do really well in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and I think
that he could transition into the movies
eventually but I think Marvel needs time
to build the character out remember all
the other versions of the character
we've seen before are from other Studios
if any of you saw Punisher warzone it
was a pretty crazy film the director of
that film is actually going to be
directing arrow this season obviously a
bit of a step down in terms of violence
but I just I think it's interesting
what's going on with Punisher right now
in pop culture if you haven't been
reading secret Wars just careful for
spoilers for Punisher and then the first
couple of issues just because he has a
really awesome appearance
you probably heard a battle world it's
just you know one world made from the
pieces of a bunch of different places in
the multiverse about a bunch of
different Earth's the story that
Punisher appears in he is like the
tether for dr. Strange's soul from
another universe so you get like Doctor
Strange Punisher the interesting thing
about that is that Doctor Strange is
really important to the defenders which
is obviously what all these Netflix
series are building up to there's a lot
of rumors that dr. strange will have a
cameo in the defenders I'm not gonna
hold my breath on that because Benedict
Cumberbatch is a really busy man really
a lot of the mysticism inside these
Netflix series is probably going to come
from the Iron Fist series just because
that's like the next best thing to
Doctor Strange that you have a lot of
his stories flow from a mystical place
you know just in the same way that dr.
Strange's stories do in the context of
the daredevil
the Punishers actually shown up in
daredevil comics a lot of times so
they're not bending canon or anything
like that to bring him on the series
Marvel's official white paper on the
character like the official synopsis
that they give us he is a vigilante who
aims to clean up New York City's Hell's
Kitchen by any means necessary no matter
how lethal the results that last bit is
the important part no matter how lethal
his description reads exactly like
Daredevils you know clean up Hell's
Kitchen by any means necessary
it's just that the Punisher as that
lethal modifier meaning he's going to be
killing a ton of people one of my
all-time favorite Punisher moments was
actually from Marvel Civil War band a
couple years ago he basically he tried
to help out Captain America's team but
they weren't having any of it this is at
the point when things had gotten really
bad too they needed all the help they
could get but they saw Punisher and they
were just like nope you know but you're
just like a little too crazy for us so
we're gonna take a hard pass Punisher
always works best when he's just
absolutely ridiculous but not so
ridiculous that he turns into Deadpool
Deadpool is is like a pure comic-book
character that's why I feel like even
the Deadpool movie is gonna like tone
the character down just like a little
bit because the essence of Deadpool is
is complete fantasy like it's a
completely unrealistic character
Punisher feels much more grata in
reality you know psychopathic hero walks
around killing people in the name of
justice he's not gonna walk around with
his severed head or anything like that
although he might sever a few heads
daredevil season 2 isn't supposed to
premiere till next year I mean it's
gonna premiere about the same time
season 1 premiered
right before Captain America Civil War
comes out just in case you guys want
some deep cuts for good daredevil
Punisher stories here a couple
suggestions you might be able to find
most of these on Marvel unlimited but
there's child's play that's a story from
daredevil 183 to 184 it's one of Frank
Miller's older stories which is a good
example of Matt Murdock protecting
villains from Frank Castle I think a
real WTF in season 2 would be daredevil
protecting Wilson Fisk from Punisher
remember as of the end of season 1
they're bitter enemies so they that'd be
just a really fun twist for Daredevils
like yeah you're the worst thing
imaginable
but you don't deserve to be gunned down
in cold blood then there's daredevil
versus Punisher which is like its own
separate comic book by itself it's
daredevil and Punisher separately like
on their own going after hammerhead
The Jackal while the kingpin is still
stuck in jail that like they're both
pursuing those villains on their own use
using their own methods Punisher of
course wants to annihilate them
daredevil just wants to get them locked
up so they end up clashing and you get a
lot of daredevil fighting Punisher which
which I feel like they're totally gonna
do in the Netflix series you can't have
a really classic daredevil versus
Punisher comic and not have a moment
like that on the TV series ultimately we
have to remember you know Punisher is a
hero so as much as he's going to be
fighting daredevil during the series
they will help each other I wouldn't be
surprised if that's the case when all
the defenders meet each other you know
Luke Cage iron fist Jessica Jones it's
kind of like the first Avengers film
whenever Thor and Iron Man went at it
for a little bit no hard feelings Point
Break you got a mean swing before this
news came along I was gonna do it
Jessica Jones video so I might push that
to later this week but just because you
know Punisher is such a big deal I think
tomorrow I'll do like my top 5 Punisher
storage from the comics so be sure to
subscribe to get that if there any you
know punisher related videos that you
guys want just let me know in the
comments and i almost forgot my marvel
giveaway starts now all it is is just
like my Game of Thrones giveaway it's a
$20 Amazon gift card all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video I'll announce the
winner whenever I post my NYX marvel
video just because of that to my normal
DC no flash arrow videos will just get
pushed by a little bit but those will
still happen this week and for those of
you they just can't stop thinking about
Walking Dead now that Shane is The
Punisher I am gonna be doing fear The
Walking Dead videos pretty soon so while
you guys wait for that stuff to drop you
can click here to learn all about
bullseye coming to daredevil season 2
he's supposed to be one of the villains
and you can click here to learn all
about legends of tomorrow thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you